[موسيقى]
رحب بمشاهدين بمستمعي مونتي كارلو الدوريه
كما نرحب بضيوف البرنامج الذين تشاهدونهم
على الشاشه ويمكنكم ان تتفاعلوا مع ما
يقولون على صفحتنا على فيسبوك او على صفحه
البرنامج على تويتر
هل تعد فعلا روسيا الانقلاب في مولدافيا
مثل ما صرحت رئيسه هذا البلد والى اي حد
قرار اغلاق المجال الجوي المولدافي يدخل
في هذا الاطار لماذا دعت فرنسا رعاياها في
بيلاروسيا للمغادره حالا هل هي مؤشرات على
ان موسكو تستعد فعلا الى هجوم واسع النطاق
على اوكرانيا في الذكرى الاولى لبدايه
الحرب نناقش الموضوع ومعي من موسكو ديمتري
بريجا وصحفي محلل سياسي معنا من كيف
لادمير شوماكوف وهو دبلوماسي سابق ودكتور
في الاقتصاد والعلوم السياسيه ومعنا من
برلين خليل عزيمه وهو اكاديمي ومحلل سياسي
اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا نستمع الى
مقالته رئيسه مردافيا
هناك تخطيط في الفتره المقبله لاعمل تخريب
من قبل مخربين تلقوا تدريبا عسكريا يرتدون
ملابس مدنيه وسيقومون باعمال عنف
ويهاجمون المباني الحكوميه وياخذون رهائن
هم يسعون لتغيير السلطه في كيشيناو من
خلال هذه الاعمال في شكل احتجاجات لما
يشبه بالمعارضه
طبعا وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
على عكس الدول الغربيه واوكرانيا نحن لا
نتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه لمولدافيا
والدول اخرى في العالم
نذهب الى موسكو معك انت بالتاكيد تسمع
مثلنا منذ فتره طويله وهناك مؤشرات
وتصريحات عديده بان موسكو تستعد بالفعل
لحسم المعركه نهائيا في اوكرانيا في
الرابع والعشرين من هذا الشهر ما صحه كل
ما نسمع وكل ما يقال في الفتره الاخيره
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم والساده المشاهدين
ولضيوفكم الكرام اعتقد بكل تاكيد الان
الكرملين يحاول حسم المعركه ما زال هناك
تقدم تكتيك للقوات الروسيه في الداخل
الاوكراني السيطره لقرى مختلفه في ان كان
في مقاطعه وغيرها من المدن ايضا من الواضح
بان الدول الغربيه بدات تقدم مزيد من
الدعم لاوكرانيا هذا الدعم يساعد القوات
الاوكرانيه في صمود في وجه يعني الضربات
الروسيه هذه الاسلحه ايضا تعطي المجال
للقوات الكري في مهاجمه ان كان شبه جزيره
القرم اول المناطق التي متواجده فيها
القوات الروسيه
تحدثنا عن مالدوبه في بكل تاكيد يعني هناك
الان مواجهه في دول الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق لمجموعات سياسيه تريد ان تكون جزءا
من روسيا وهناك مجموعات سياسيه تريد ان
تكون جزء من العائله الاوروبيه ودول
الاتحاد الاوروبي فهذه المواجهه بعدت الان
واضحه حتى في كازاخستان هناك قوه يعني
التوجه الروسي او الفكر الذي يسميه البعض
العالم الروسي حتى في اوكرانيا نعرف بان
هناك كان حزب يعني كان يدعم ان تكون
اوكرانيا جزءا من روزف هذه المواجهه الان
ايضا باتت موجوده في مضافا فواضح بان يعني
التغييرات التي ايضا تحدث فيها الدول
اتحاد السوفيتي السابق تؤثر على هذه
المواجهه وايضا وجود الدور الروسي الان في
المنطقه ويعني الخطاب السياسي الذي يواجه
يعني يرسله الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
للمجموعات السياسه والاحزاب السياسيه التي
تدعم ان تكون يعني جزءا من روسيا او جزءا
مع بتحالف مع روسيا كما كانت في زمن
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق فواضح بان يعني
الان هذه المواجهه بدات يعني تظهر في دول
اتحاد السوفيتي السابق ان كان في جورجيا
او في ارمينيا او في كازاخستان يعني واضح
بان اذا ما تحدث عن الصراع الروسي
الاوكراني فواضح بان الان ما يسميه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بالعمليه العسكريه
الخاصه بدات يعني حتى في الداخل الروسي
يسمونها بالحرب لانها الدول الغربيه دول
التحالف دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بدات ترسل
تعزيزات وتدرب القوات الاوكرانيه اذا نحن
في حاله مواجهه قوتين قوه يعني قوه الحلف
الشمال الاطلسي او تحالف حلف الشمال
الاطلسي وروسيا والدول التي تدعمها ولذلك
يعني الان المواجهه بدات اكبر من ما كانت
عليه في السابق عندما كان يسميها الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بالعمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا طيب فلاديمير يعني حتى
عدد كبير من المسؤولين في اوكرانيا
يتوقعونه هجوما واسعا النطاق على اوكرانيا
في الفتره القليله المقبله سمعنا حتى
زيلينسكي يتحدث عن هذا الكلام هناك
المؤشرات تزداد يوما بعد يوم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
وتحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا سؤالك جميل نحن
نشهد بان روسيا بدات بصراحه هجوم في منطقه
تحاول ان احتلال هذا بصراحه جيش رقم اثنين
في العالم يحاول الاحتلال منطقه الباص
لمده
سنه تقريبا انا منذ ايام رجعت من جنوب
اوكرانيا من مدينه خرسانه ونحن وجدنا هناك
جدا هناك عدد قليل جدا من المدرعات
والدبابات الان روسيا حاشده قواتها في
منطقه
وكمان في منطقه الضنبع واحد نحن نشهد
بصراحه بانو روسيا غير استراتيجيه هي الان
تعزز قواتها في منطقه واحده من
وهي تحاول ان تهاجم على اوكرانيا
هذا حرب استراتيجيا هدف اساسي عند روسيا
تغير نظام في اوكرانيا هذا احتلال فيه
واحتلال اوكرانيا لماذا لانه روسيا تاريخه
منطقه نفوز روسيه ولكن هذا من الاربع
مستحيلات اوكرانيا سوف تحصل على كل
الاسلحه مطلوبه ومنها ضربات ومدرعات من
غارب في اخر كمان كما
دائما اقول خسائر روسيه هي الضخمه بوتين
عند بوتين لا يوجد لا توجد اي رحمه على
الجنود الروسيه من المعروف خلال هذه 12
شهر مقتولا اكثر من 130 جنديا روسيا يعني
اوكرانيا دمرت مخبعه عسكريه روسيه هل سوف
يكون
هجوم شامل من جانب الروسي انا لا اعطاك
طبيان سوف يكون هجوم روسي في شمال
اوكرانيا وكمان في جنوب في محافظه خرسوم
من المنتظر بين روسيا سوف تهاجم بشكل كبير
على اوكرانيا في منطقه وكمان من الممكن في
من محافظ
طيب خليل تبعت ما قاله الضيف من موسكو
وايضا الضيف من من
الان حسب ما فهمت من ضيفي من موسكو ان
بوتين نجح في اقناع رايه العام بان هذه
الحرب اصبحت حربا بين روسيا والدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول منظمه ومنظمه
الناتو اذن العمليه الان
تقريبا العمليه العسكريه لم تعد عمليه
عسكريه خاصه وانا اصبحت الحرب
تحياتي لكم ومشاهدينا الكرام وعلى ضيوفكم
من موسكو من المدينه الحبيبه على قلبنا
كيف
هي بالبدايه حرب وليست عمليه عسكريه وهذه
هذا التلاعب بالمصطلحات فشل بوتين في
اقناع العالم بان هذه عمليه عسكريه خاصه
هي حرب اباده ضد الامه الاوكرانيه المشكله
الاساسيه بين روسيا واوكرانيا هي ان روسيا
لا تعترف بالامه الاوكرانيه والامه
الاوكرانيه هي موجوده شاءت روسيا ايضا يجب
ان نذكر ان غياب اقدم من اي اقدم مدينه في
روسيا عمليا
بالفعل
بوتين او روسيا منذ البدايه حاولت اقناع
الراي الداخلي الروسي بان
الاوحد او نظام الشمولي لذلك يحاول دائما
تحاول روسيا دائما اقناع بان الحرب هي ضد
النيتو وهناك تصريحات من جميع
القيادات العليا الغربيه
انه لن ننظر بدايه انه لن يكون هناك ارسال
اي جنود او اي افراد الى الداخل الاوكراني
طيب قليل لا يوجد رساله افراد ولكن
الاسلحه تتطور تدريجيا بدانا باسلحه خفيفه
الان نتحدث عن دبابات الطلب الان في
طائرات اذا منظمه حلف شمال لاسي ودول
اوروبيه كبيره تقف بشكل واضح عسكريا الى
جانب اوكرانيا وهذا ما تردده مختلف الصحف
الاوروبيه يعني ليس ليس سرا طبعا بالتاكيد
هل تريد العالم ان يقف يتفرج كيف ما تريده
ما روسيا هي ان تذبح الشعب الاوكراني
والعالم يتفرج على ذلك هذا غير منطقي
روسيا نفسها تستعين بالسلاح من دول اخرى
لذلك لماذا يحرم على اوكرانيا الدفاع عن
نفسها باستخدام اسلحه غربيه
والناتو الان كما قلت انه
يرسل المزيد والمزيد من الاسلحه لانه اصبح
على يقين بان الجيش الروسي لن يقف في
اوكرانيا اذا انتصروا وانما سيمتد الى
كامل الشرق الاوروبي وهناك
حلم روسي باعاده الامبراطوريه الروسيه
وبعاده الاتحاد السوفيتي بصيغه جديده وهذا
ما رايناه بشكل كبير او ما سمعناه من حسب
التصريحات
المسؤولين حول
القوميه الروسيه والعرق الروسي
والامبراطوريه الروسيه وهذه الدول هي
تابعه على روسيا وسمعنا كثيرا من انه لا
يوجد بالاساس هناك دوله اسمها اوكرانيا كل
هذا يؤكد ان هناك اسماء لدى روسيا اطماع
توسعيه باعاده سيطرتها على اوروبا الشرقيه
لاحياء ما كان موجودا في ايام الاحتلال
السوفيتي
روسيا لادا لديها اطماع توسعيه فيما يتعلق
بمولدافيا مثلا فيما يتعلق بدول اخرى
مجاوره لاوكرانيا الان تم ضبط خارطه
الطريق في ذهنيه الروس ضروره الاستمرار في
الحرب وعدم التراجع كلف ذلك ما كلف
بصراحه نحن نشهد كارثه حقيقيه في الغرب
والشرق الان هناك كارثه في الشرق من موضوع
الزلزال الذي حدث في تركيا والسرور لا
نشهد ايضا كارثه في الغرب حيث نشهد صراعا
بين روسيا والدول الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا
نحن اذا تحدثنا عن يعني المخطط الرئيسي
للرئيس الروسي فواضح بانه يريد من الدول
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق ودول التي مجاوره
لروسي لتكون اقرب لرؤيه روسيا لانه يرى
بان اي دول تكون جزءا من الحلف الشمالي
الاطلسي او دول الاتحاد الاوروبي يمكن ان
تهدد مصالح روسيا يمكن ان تهدد الامن
القومي الروسي ما تحدث عنه في السابق عن
اوكرانيا وعن موضوع ان تكون اوكرانيا جزء
من حلف الشمال الاطلس او حتى ان تكون جزء
من الاتحاد الاوروبي وكان يرى بان ان اذا
كانت اوكرانيا او ضمت اوكرانيا للاتحاد
الاوروبي او حلف الشمال لا تصي سوف تقطون
تهديدا مباشرا
يعني روسيا تتذكر عندما حدث التغييرات في
اوكرانيا عام 2014 وهرب فيكتور يعني كان
ليس ولكن كان اقرب لرؤيه روسيا في الملف
الداخلي او في السياسه الداخليه
الاوكرانيه بدا موقف الكريم لن يتغير تجاه
يعني اوكرانيا وتجاه الملفات الداخليه
الاوكرانيه وبدا الرئيس الروسي الذي تحدث
اكثر عن الدفاع عن القوميه الروسيه في
الداخل الاوكراني وعن مشاكل التي تواجهها
القوميه الروسيه في اوكرانيا اذا نحن نشهد
الان حاله من التوتر الذي يمكن يسبب حربا
كبيره بكل تاكيد الواضح بان يعني الان
هناك تجهيزات لروسيا اقصد هنا تجهيزات
عسكريه وهناك ايضا يعني تدريب عسكري لبعض
لبعض الجنود الذين كانوا وصلوا حديثا من
التعبئه الجزئيه الى في مراكز التدريب
هناك الان ايضا تدريب مشترك للقوات
الروسيه على الاراضي البيلاروسيه اذا نحن
نشهد حاله من الخطير في
يعني في بين روسيا ودول الاتحاد الاوروبيا
وحلف الشمال الاطلسي الذي يمكن ان يسبب
حربا كبيره لانه راينا بوتين بدا يدخل
الانظمه الجديده في الحرب ادخال منظومه
سيركون في فرقات وايضا يعني ادخال انظمه
جديده
ومطالبه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من شركه
روستيق بصناعه انظمه الدفاع الجوي اذا
يعني هذه الحاله حتى واضح في موسكو عندما
بدات
الحكومه في موسكو تضع انظمه للدفاع اس 300
في محيط
موسكو ونظام دفاع لاسقاط المسيرات في داخل
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو اذا هناك استعداد
لحرب او لصراع كبير بين حلف الشمال لطفي
وروسيا لانه واضح بان بوتين لن يتراجع عن
ما بداوا في اوكرانيا هو يريد ان ينجح
تنجح الخطه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
خطه القياده العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
لذلك هو لن يستسلم في الملف الاوكراني في
الوضع الحالي لان هناك اولا انتخابات
مقبله عام 2024 والذي يعني من الواضح بين
الرئيس الروسي سوف يترشح فيها ايضا يعني
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا هناك
انتخابات والحزب الديمقراطي يريد ان يقدم
للشعب الامريكي مكان يعني يقدمه في
البرنامج ما كان يريده
الحزب الديمقراطي في اوكرانيا لم ينجح في
الملف الاوكراني فسوف يواجه مشكله داخليه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا نحن
نواجه الان صراعا قد يتحول الى حرب كبيره
بين اطراف كثيره
هذا السيناريو الذي يتحدث عنه
حرب روسيا في فخر ولكن بوتين هو وصل شخصيا
في في هذا الفاخر كل هذه المزاعم حول
انضمام اوكرانيا الى
قبل هذه الذريه لهجوم على اوكرانيا لنتذكر
قبل حرب اعلن او كشف امين الناتو اوكرانيا
لن تدخل في الناتو في اقرب عشره سنوات
ولكن روسيا يستخدمت هذه
ذرية لهجوم على اوكرانيا ولكن الان بصراحه
في اوكرانيا نحن كل شيء ثاني يعني بان بعض
انتصار في اوكرانيا عندنا شواغل جديه بين
روسيا سوف تهاجم على اوكرانيا مره ثانيه
بهذا السبب صيغه ذهبيه لاوكرانيا انضمام
الى الناتو ان ناتو هو ضمان بيوكرانيا
تهاجم على اوكرانيا مره ثانيه وكمان نحن
نقول من الضروري انسحاب من روسيا اسلحه
نوويه
من روسيا قال حول حرب بين الناتو وروسيا
والله هذا من الاربعه مستحيلات من
المستحيل ان مقارنه قوه الروسيه وقوه
الناتو نحن هنا في اوكرانيا بصراحه
بالروسيا هي متخلفه التكنولوجيا عسكريا
جدا
مقارنه
بمقارنه مع روسيا مع اوكرانيا ان روسيا
قويه ولكن بمقارنه مع ضرب اكيد لا هذا
السبب موجود صمود قوات مصالحه اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا تحصل على كل من الاسلحه المطلوبه
لهجوم مضاد ناجح ولتحرير لمناطق اوكرانيه
المحتله كما نحن نقول هنا في اوكرانيا من
الضروري تاسيس في اقرب في اقرب الوقت
محكمه جنائيه خاصه حاول جرائم بوتين هنا
في اوكرانيا بالمناسبه من الضروري تاسيس
ناصر المحكمه حول الجرائم بوتين في سوريا
طيب خليل الا ترى ان هناك لاعب بالنار
عندما نسمع هذا النوع من الكلام
بالتاكيد هناك لا رجعه في هذا الامر ولكن
اعتقد ان هناك سيكون قريبا هجوم روسيه
ستحاول روسيا على الاقل السيطره على
الحدود الجغرافيه لاقليم الدمباس وبعدها
يمكن ان تبدا بشكل غير مباشر
بطلب الى هدنه والوصول الى المحاذاه
السلام
ونعود الى المربع الاول
واحد واثنين وثلاثه الى اخره ولكن الموقف
الاوكراني اعتقد انه لن يتغير لن تكون
هناك مفاوضات مع روسيا قبل الانسحاب
الروسي بشكل كامل الى حدود ال 24 فبراير
ومن ثم بدء المفاوضات لذلك ما زال الوضع
خطير جدا
سيكون هناك تصعيد بشكل كبير ولكن ليس كما
نسمع بالتصري
من حيث استخدام الاسلحه النوويه روسيا لن
تستخدم الاسلحه النوويه لاسباب كثيره
منها سبب هام جدا انها هناك قسم كبير من
الاسلحه هو من الحقبه السوفيتيه يمكن ان
يكون خرج من الخدمه بالتقادم وبالتالي فقد
دقته وهناك امكانيه ان تسقط هذه رؤوس
النوويه في اي منطقه حتى في اوروبا لذلك
استبعد تماما استخدام روسيا للسلاحه
النووي هي تستخدم ما تبقى من اسلحه وتعتمد
حاليا على
القوه البشريه والقصف الشامل وراينا ان
خلال الفتره الماضيه التقدم هو بضع
عشرات الامتار راينا باخمد اكثر من شهرين
وهناك ليس هناك تقدم اذا هناك عمليا
الحدود في المعركه
تجمدت الى حد ما سوف على الربيع
وبمرور ذكرى السنويه الاولى يمكن ان يكون
هناك تصعيد ولكن لا اعتقد ان التصعيد سيصل
الى مواجهه مباشره مع الناتو لان الامن
مصلحه روسيا المباشره رغم انها حاولت جر
الناتو الى مواجهه مباشره ولكن
الاختلاف في موازين القوى فيجعل ان سيجعل
دخول الناتو في بشكل مباشر في الحرب مشاكل
كبيره في روسيا نفسها ويمكن ان يؤدي الى
تفكك روسيا نفسها لان التوازن ليس هناك
توازن بين قوه الناتو وقوه روسيا وراينا
كما كما ذكرت قبل قليل ان في مدينه صغيره
مثل تعجز الجيش الثاني في العالم يعجز عن
احتلالها من خلال فتره عشرات الايام او
اكثر من شهرين يقوم بعمليات هجوم ولا
يستطيع
احتلالها اذا هناك بس استبعد انا شخصيا
هنا ان هناك سيكون
صراع مع الناتو ولكن نضع ايضا بين قوسين
كنت في مثل هذا الوقت من العام الماضي
استبعد تماما نشوب الحرب كنت كنت
اعتمد على ان هناك في القياده الروسيه
هناك نخبه ستفكر عقلانيا وستفكر لمصلحه
روسيا ولن تدخل في حرب ولكن اخطات انا في
تقديري ان هناك لن يكون هناك حرب على اغلب
القنوات قلت انها لن تكون هناك حرب ولكن
حصلت هذا الحرب الان ايضا من حيث المنطق
لن تكون هناك مواجهه كبرى ما بين الناتو
وروسيا ولن تكون هناك عالميه ثالثه كما
يروج لها البعض وعند استخدام اسلحه نوويه
لذلك انا متفائل في هذا الوضع ان العمليه
فقط ستكون في اوكرانيا وستنتهي لصالح
اوكرانيا بنصر اوكرانيا واسترجاع اراضيها
ممكن ان تكون في معارك ويمكن ان تكون من
المفاوضه سلبيه طيب ديمتري مساحه الكلام
الذي نقراه ونسمعه على لسان اكثر من
اخصائي وخبير بان روسيا حتى الان استخدمت
اسلحه قديمه وانها تركت جانبا الاسلحه
المتطوره كي تستخدمها في مرحله الحسم وما
تسميها بمرحله حسب هذه الحرب
اعتقد استعن يعني هناك بعض الاسلحه التي
لم يتم استعمالها حتى الان في
الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه ولكن واضح كما تحدث
ضيفكم انه الان يحاولون كل الاطراف
يحاولون حسب المعركه في الداخل اوكرانيا
يعني في الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه لا يريدون
ان تخرج المعركه الى خارج الجغرافيا
الاوكرانيه لان هذا الشيء قد يسبب حربا
كبيره ولا اعتقد حتى دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
جاهزه لهذه الحرب اعتقد بان في نهايه
الامر حتى راينا يعني هناك كانت تصريحات
من المانيا تصريحات من دول كثيره بان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ليست جاهزه لحروب كبيره
لان هذه المواجهه قد تسبب مشاكل كبيره في
العمق الاوروبي لذلك يعني الان كل الاطراف
يحاولون حسب المعركه في الجغرافيا
الاوكرانيه ولا يريدون ان يخرجوا خارج
الجغرافيا الاوكراني لا اعتقد حتى الطرف
الروسي جاهز الان لان تخرج المعركه خارج
الجغرافي الاوكرانيه لان هذه المعركه قد
تسبب مشاكل لوجستيه قد تسبب ايضا مشاكل
داخليه لانه قد قد يحتاج الجيش الروسي
لتعبئه اخرى ونتذكر كان هناك بعض المشاكل
حتى من يعني الرئيس الروسي تحدث عنها
بموضوع تعبئه الجزئيه اذا الان كل طرف
يحاول حسم المعركه في جغرافيا واحد وهي
الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه حتى بوجود الاسلحه
الحديثه التي التي تقدمها
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كل طرف يفهم بان لا يجب ان تخرج
المعركه خارج الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه لان
هذا الشيء قد يضر كل الاطراف ولا احد يريد
ان
تحدث حرب عالميه ثالثه في الوقت الحالي
الذي نشهد فيها يعني كوارث مختلفه في
العالم
لاحظت من خلال تصريحات الاوروبيه فيما
يتعلق بطلب اوكرانيا لدبابات الدول
العديد من الدول وافقت على منح اوكرانيا
دبابات ولكن مساله تسليم الدبابات الكل
يتحدث عن مارس او عن شهر ابريل ولا يتحدث
مع ان التهديدات الان تتعلق بالذكرى
الاولى لهذه الحرب كيف فهمتم هذه الرساله
من قبل الدول التي اعلنت بانها مستعده
لتزويدكم بالدبابات
جميل بصراحه كما انا قلت في بدايه
اوكرانيا سوف تحصل على كل المعاضره
العسكريه مطلوبه في اقرب وقت او في شهر
مارس او في شهر ابريل لان نحن كمان ندركه
بان موجود مشاكل
اتحاد الاوروبي وفي واحد من الضروري تدريب
القوات جنوط اوكرانيا يعني باستخدامها كل
هذه الاسلحه متطوره يعني هذا تحتاج للوقت
اوكرانيا تحتاج هذه الدبابات الثقيله
لهجوم على قوات مصالحه روسيه لاختراق
الدفاعات روسي خاصه في جنوب اوكرانيا
للدخول قوات مصالحه في شبه تقرير لتحرير
هذا المنطقه في اقرب وقت بمناسبه ويقولون
خبراء لان اسهل لقوات مصالحه اوكرانيا
تحرير ان شبه
ليست منطقه ولكن على كل حال اوكرانيا سوف
تحرر وكمان شبه
منطقه
عند روسيا كما نحن نشهد معدات عسكريه
قديمه وعند روسيا حجه اخيره هذا استخدام
اسلحه نوويه على اوكرانيا بشكل
دعم نحن نسمعه تهديدات من قوات مصالح
روسيه باستخدام هذه الاسلحه وهذا بسبب حقد
في عقرب
سوف تكون عنيفه للغايه في منطقه
وفي محافظه الزباريج وبهذا السبب اوكرانيا
تحتاج كل هذه عسكريه في اقرب الوقت
طيب خليل الان انت تبعت عند التصريحات
موسكو كانت واضحه وفهمنا منها ان دخول
دبابات الى اوكرانيا من الغرب بمثابه خط
احمر وسيتم حرقها مثل مقاله حتى وزير
الخارجيه وزير الدفاع الروسي وايضا الرئيس
الروسي اذا المرحله الصعبه بالنسبه للجميع
تتزامن مع دخول هذه الدبابات الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه له
سمعنا هذا الكلام عندما تم ايضا الحديث عن
تزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ غيرا هذا
التصريحات هي كما بدات كلامي هي الاستهلاك
المحلي الروسي لاحظنا طبعا اريد ان انوه
ان روسيا استخدمت كل ما عندها من اسلحه من
صواريخ مجنحه الى فرصه صوتيه لذلك لم يبقى
عندها الا استخدام لم تستخدمه الا الاسلحه
النوويه راينا في الفتره الماضيه ضعف في
اداء الصواريخ والهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه
على المناطق السكنيه والبنيه التحتيه في
اوكرانيا
هذا
يدل على ان المنظومه الدفاع الجويه
الاوكرانيه تحسد بشكل كبير ووصل في اخر
اخر هجمه صاروخيه نستطيع ان نقدر ان فقط
10% من
الصواريخ حققت بعض اهدافها لذلك
حده القتال بالنسبه لروسيا انخفضت مع قدوم
الدبابات ايضا ستنخفض هذه الحده بسبب
سيكون هناك ارتفاع في المقاومه الاوكرانيه
لذلك موضوع اننا سنحرق الدبابات في مكانها
كما قالوا سابقا انهم سيفجروا الصواريخ
هايبر في مكانها هذا كله للاستهلاك المحلي
ولكن عمليا نرى هناك الى حد ما حتى نكون
متوازنين الى حد ما هناك ضعف في الاداء
الروسي
وايضا دليل على ذلك
اعتماد روسيا على الطائرات الانتحاريه
الايرانيه
التقارير ايضا تشير الى حصول روسيا على
صواريخ من كوريا لذلك هذا ايضا دليل على
ان القدره القتاليه الروسيه انخفضت الان
روسيا تعتمد على بشكل كبير على قوات
فانجرز وبالتالي اصبح الجيش النظامي
يسير خلف ميليشيات او مرتزقه
لذلك لا اعتقد ان
روسيا ستستطيع حرق هذه الدبابات في مكانها
الدبابات عند دخولها الى المعركه ايضا
تقلب المعادله كما قلبت الصواريخ قبل ذلك
المعادله وراينا في الصيف تحرير شرق
اوكرانيا
وبالتالي ستستمر هذه العمليه كما قلت انا
ستحاول روسيا الان في عمليه جديده لاحكام
السيطره على اراضي الدومباس وعندها
ستعود من جديد الى المطالبه بوقف اطلاق
النار والمحادثات مع بحيث انها
توهم انها تتنازل عن ما يسمى ضمته ما يسمى
بالاستفتاء المزيف مضمته من اراضي مقابل
الاحتفاظ بالقرب والضباس ولكن لا اعتقد ان
اي احد من اوكرانيا من الجيش او من الشعب
او من او حتى الرئيس سيوافق على التخلي عن
اي مترين او جزء من التراب الاوكراني لذلك
سنشهد في القريب
ارتفاع شده المعارك ولكن
الدبابات اعتقد ستصل في نهايه شهر مارس او
ابريل وهذا الوقت المناسب الذي يتوقع يمكن
ان يكون هناك حركه جديده من المعارك بسبب
ذوبان الجليد وهذا ايضا سيكون لصالح الجيش
الاوكراني
نذكر جميعا كيف
دمرت اذكار الدبابات الروسيه في مثل هذا
الوقت من العام الماضي في ابريل على
في رواحي كيا شاهدنا ذلك كيف كانت
الدبابات مدمره على هذا على طرق لذلك
الوقت الان هو لصالح اوكرانيا والتسليح
يجب ان يكون بشكل سريع لقلب المعادله بشكل
اكبر معجمود بالتحرك القوات الروسيه وهذا
ما رايناه حتى في الاعلام الروسي هناك في
برنامج سياسي مشهور ومقدمه البرنامج
مشهوره جدا قالت بالحرف الواحد ضيوفها
لماذا اوكرانيا تتقدم بالقرى ونحن تقدم
بالامتار اذا هناك تدمر روسي من حتى في
روسيا نفسها تدمر القيادات وراينا ذلك
ايضا من خلال تغيير المتكرر القيادات
الروسيه في المعركه
اريد ان اسالك على ظهور ظهور يعني
دائم تقريبا في الفتره الاخيره
للمسؤول عن فاجنر لم نكن نسمعه لم نكن حتى
نراه لم نكن نرى والان هو يتحدث عن مواضيع
عسكريه على سبيل المثال يقول لان المعركه
لم نكسب المعركه بعد باء في في في في
باخموت مثلا او يعطي اماكن اخرى يعني ظهور
هذا الرجل بهذا الشكل العلني كيف يمكن ان
نفهمه نحن في الغرب مع ان روسيا في
البدايه نفذت كليا حتى وجود مثل هذه
المجموعه
بكل تاكيد واضح بان اذا تحدثت عن شركه لها
تاثير كبير على في ساحات المعارك تحولت
الى من شركه امنيه خاصه الى يعني شركه حتى
تعمل في داخل الروسي بالتجاره ولا هي مركز
في مدينه سامبول سبورت والتي تهتم بمشاريع
التجاريه في داخل الروسي اذا هذه الشركه
الان تحولت الى شركه تلعب دورا مهما في
المعارك في اوكرانيا ايضا يعني لها دور في
ملفات كثيره تخص يعني السياسه الخارجيه
الروسيه ولكن واضح بان الان يعني
ظهورشن هو ايضا ظهور للشركه الى انه راينا
يعني هناك بعض يعني افكار مختلفه ووجهات
نظر مختلفه بين يعني الشخصيات قياديه في
روسيا عن شركه فاقنر ولكن ظهور
رسميا في ساحات المعارك هو يعطي الانطباع
الشركه موجوده وتلعب دورا مهما
يعني
يرى بان وجود هذه الشركه الان او حتى يعني
وسائل الاعلام تتحدث بين وجود هذه الشركه
قد بدا يلعب دورا مهما في المعارك لانه
هذه القوات لها اكثر تحفيز للقتال ضد
القوات الاوكرانيه ان كان راينا في
سوليدار وفي منطقه باركود حتى من تصريحات
رسميه من الطرف الاوكراني بان القوات
دائما تواصل الهجوم على هذه المناطق
وتستعمل استراتيجيات مختلفه ايضا لا ننسى
بان تم اخذ بعض الجنود من السجون يعني حتى
من كما تحدثت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه من
السجون وتدريبهم على القتال اذا يعني
الشركه يعني بدات تتحول الان كما قلت الى
شركه تجاريه في داخل الروسي بفتح مركز في
مدينه
سامبرسبورغ والتي تساعد رجال الاعمال
والمشاريع المختلفه التجاريه في الداخل
الروسي وايضا شركه امنيه خاصه تلعب دورا
مهما دورا مهما الان في اوكرانيا وحتى
نتذكر كما تحدثت وسائل الاعلام مختلفه في
دول اخرى طيب هل هذا يعني مجموعه
اعطت الدليل بان اقوى من القوات الروسيه
وما يمكن ان تقف في وجه القوات الاوكرانيه
بشكل اوضح واكبر مما تفعله القوات الروسيه
لان هذا كذا فهم الامر على الاقل من جانب
الغربي
هو ليس نوع من يعني شركه باقدر هي اقوى من
يعني الجيش الروسي
ولكنر هم يعني متدربون في حرب الشوارع
نتذكر بان كان هناك وسائل الاعلام تتحدث
عن وجود شركه فاكتور في سوريا في مناطق
مختلفه في حرب الشوارع التي كانت ضد
مجموعات مختلفه الان قوات فارغنر يمكن ان
تلعبوا دورا مهما حتى الان في المعارك في
اوكرانيا في حرب الشوارع في المدن والقرى
التي لا يستطيع لا تستطيع القوات النظاميه
تمشيطها وحتى نعرف بان ايضا للرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قديره مجموعه خاصه به
هوايه مجموعه اخماد سيلا والتي ايضا تلعب
دورا في المعارك ان كان في باك موت او في
سوليدارا وفي في مقاطعه لان القوات
النظاميه لا تستطيع الهجوم كما يعني
المجموعات الخاصه وشركات الامنيه الخاصه
او مجموعات يعني تم تدريب على قتال
الشوارع شركه فا لديها يعني كما تتحدث
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه مراكز تدريب تدرب
القوات فيها ايضا هناك كما قلت سجناء
سابقين تم ادخاله في المعارك اذن يعني هذا
الشيء ايضا للداخل الروسي لان ارسال اعداد
كبيره من التعبئه الجزئيه للمعارك وهذا
الشيء قد يسبب مشاكل في الداخل الروسي اما
اعتماد على شركه
هو يعني اكثر
امنا او اكثر
يعني يعطي اكثر انتقال داخل الروسي بعدم
وجود اي مشاكل للجنود الذين وصلوا في
التعبئه الجزئيه لان هذا الشيء قد قتله
مقتل هذه المجموعه من الجنود التي وصلوا
تعبئه الجزئيه قد يسبب مشاكل داخليه طيب
فلاديمير يعني دخول فاجنر على الخط يطرح
المزيد من الاشكاليات بالنسبه للجيش
الاوكراني له
سؤالك كان جميل جدا قابل هل قوات مصالحه
اقوى من جيش روسي هذا صحيح بصراحه خطا من
المعروف بان مجموعه يستخدمون السجناء
ويستخدمون بدون اي رحمه بالمناسبه في
اوكرانيا
من
واحد داخل روسيا بين الجيش الروسي ومجموعه
التواتر الكبير ومنافسه وكمان معروف يعني
وزير الدفاع
كلاهما اعداء هذا معروف حتى الان نحن نسمع
بعض الاشتباكات بالكلام بينهما يعني على
كل حال من المنتظر
لن تكون
لا تكون هجومه من جانب مجموعه
اوكرانيا
من كثره قتاليه
ولكن نحن نشهد بان روسيا الان تعزز قواتها
في منطقه دنباص ومن المنتظر وهجوم شامل في
هذه المنطقه يعني من المعروف
وزير الدفاعات روسيا تحرير
او احتلال احتلال كل من
روسيا تحارب مع اوكرانيا على منطقه من سنه
2014 عندما روسي هجمت غدرا على منطقه
الباص واحتلت تقريبا 30% من هذا وخلق هناك
جمهوريتين غير متعرفين بها انا اعطاك بان
روسيا سوف تحتل كل هذا المنطقه بالمناسبه
هو كمان كشف اليوم بان الصراع على موسى
سوف تكون دمويه للغايه
لن تكون فيها نجاحا
لقوات مصالحه روسيه طيب خليل اذا
الجغرافيا السياسيه في المنطقه على صفيحه
ساخن
بالتاكيد هي صحيح ساخن منذ عام 2021 عندما
بدات الحشد القوات الروسيه والمناوات
الروسيه البيلاروسيه المنطقه تحول الى
صفيح ساخن لكن هناك
مقايضات مع ملفات اخرى يمكن ان تهدئ من
هذا الصفيح الان روسيا تحاول من خلال هذه
العمليات وهذه الاحداث ان تخلق
قطب جديده في العالم ولكن استطاعت دعنا
نقول انا بالفعل استطاعت روسيا ان تكون
قطبا ولكن ليس قطبا عالميا وانما قطبا
اقليميا استطاعت ان تجمع حولها بعض الدول
من خلال اللعب
المشاعر وخاصه مثلا
على سبيل المثال في العالم العربي روسيا
تلعب على مشاعر عداء العالم العربي للدول
الغربيه والولايات المتحده بسبب القضايا
العربيه تلعب على هذه المشاعر لكسب
التعاطف العربي مع روسيا وتصور وروسيا
تصور لهم ان حرب هي مع الامبرياليه
والامريكيه الى اخره لذلك
سيكون هناك تنافس كبير ولكن
الموقف الصيني الى الان هو لاعب دور في
تخفيف شده الصراع في المنطقه وتطوره الى
مواجهات عالميه من خلال ان الصين لم تدعم
هذه لن تدعم روسيا في هذه الحرب ولم تعترف
بضب
الاراضي المحتله الاوكرانيه لذلك هذا خفف
من حده الصراع ان ينتقل الى صراع دولي و
ينتقل الى حرب عالميه لذلك
نؤكد ان للاسف ان ستكون هذه المعارك فقط
على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا ايضا رغبه غربيه
ونلاحظ الغرب يرفض دائما اعطاء اوكرانيا
اسلحه بعيده المدى حتى ان حتى داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه مثل القرن لا تصل هذه
الاسلحه الى او هذه الصواريخ التي تزود
اوكرانيا تزود بها اوكرانيا لا تصل الى
اراضي القرن وهذا من الضروري للجيش
الاوكراني لضرب الدفاع خلف الدفاع الخطوط
الدفاعيه لذلك كل الدول الغربيه وحتى
روسيا يحافظون على ان تكون هذه الصراعات
داخل منطقه جغرافيه محدده ولا تنتقل الى
المساحه العالميه ولكن هنا سيلعب دور كما
قلت يمكن ان يكون هناك مقايضه في ملفات
معينه روسيا خسرت ملف الغاز
الان تعمل مع
تركيا لكسب ملفات اخرى في الشرق الاوسط
مثلا وبالتالي يمكن ان يكون هناك تغيرات
سياسيه في منطقه ولكن ليس لن تكون هناك
وهذا ما امله ان لا تكون هناك مواجهه
عالميه فالشكر في الختام من موسكو
محلل سياسي شكر من كيبل فلاديمير دبلوماسي
سابق ودكتور في الاقتصاد والعلوم السياسيه
وشكرا لخليل عزيمه اكاديمي ومحلل سياسي
شكرا لفريق البرنامج امسيه مريحه للجميع